so CNN's Don Lemon has gotten in a lot
of hot water this week for some comments
he made which originally started when
Bill O'Reilly made some comments in the
aftermath of the Trayvon Martin case and
Bill O'Reilly's been talking a lot about
black-on-black crime and he's been
getting a lot of guff from from liberals
saying you know he has no right to talk
about it and well let's let's watch the
clip one of those honest people CNN
anchor Don Lemon who referenced my
talking points on his program he's got a
point
in fact he's got more than a point bill
raised without much structure young
black men often reject education and
gravitate towards the street culture
drugs hustling gangs nobody forces them
to do that again it is a personal
decision he is right about that too but
in my estimation he doesn't go far
enough miss lemon then went on to list
things that African Americans should do
to combat social problems after his
remarks mr. lemon was predictably
attacked by the race hustlers but his
courage stands in stark contrast to
their ignorance and corruption I should
say by the way Don is Don Lemon is a
friend of mine so in full disclosure
something I don't know something like
that no but I don't know might affect my
opinion on this somehow first off can I
confirm we're all white here is that
fair to say very white white white white
okay so part of me was thinking can we
even talk about this so that's where I
want to start on is the racial stuff I
think partly what's going on here is
that the black community doesn't want
bill o'reilly talking about their dirty
laundry that i don't think they're
necessarily disagreeing with the heart
of it and that's what Don's talking
about but they just don't want someone
like Bill O'Reilly talking about it so
is that in itself Gargamel's like no
reference he doesn't you know he's not
really with the times necessarily is not
out even socializing probably right now
he does his job and he you know
has a dinner and goes home yells are the
staff squeeze his staff fire somebody
goes home so she your point I always
first went talking about these things
they add somebody who is not black I
can't necessarily speak on their
experience with this of course you can
serve an opinion right of course the
thing is I what I don't understand about
what Bill O'Reilly said is why it's it's
just your main to black teens you know
black kids in general I think black kids
in general kids in general yeah
gravitate towards that kind of thing
especially you know economically
disadvantaged kids so it's not strictly
a black problem right you know I think
you know if you if you go the Jesse
Pinkman route you're gonna have a tough
time getting jobs that is a white
problem and a black problem if you if
you dress and look and you know if you
if you act any any way that is sort of
outside of Corporate America you're at a
disadvantage it's not it's not hateful
thing it becomes a hateful thing when
you're Bill O'Reilly and you say that
it's only black kids who do that right
yeah but the people that are defending
O'Reilly are saying he's bringing up a
legitimate argument that yes the trave I
Bill O'Reilly knocked him I don't think
at least he doesn't seem to be
diminishing what happened with Trayvon
at all or even defending Zimmerman it
seems to me that he's trying to address
a separate issue which is the the black
background but it's just simply they
don't hear from and also the fact that
he attached it to the Trayvon Martin
thing if you still want to attach the
fact that this kid should be dead in
anyway because he was wearing a hoodie
or because he looked maybe a little like
like he wasn't on his way to his
corporate job with his briefcase you
know and How to Succeed in Business
Without Really Trying musical style yeah
you know then that's a serious problem
because I know Riley is kind of still
saying oh you brought it upon yourself
it's like that is I think why people
have a little bit of outrage with him
because with him and what he says it's
never really just about what he's
talking about
okay so then that's where we should
bring it well then that's where we
should bring in Don Lemon because Don
Lemon is black and he is acknowledging
that he's trying to address that you
know pull up your pants and Martin are
you doing it in terms of jobs in the
workplace because if he's saying look
you know as a black man on television
using some sort of position of influence
he's saying yo black people in our city
yeah hey there black folk I don't know
how he's addressing them besides the
fact that he's saying to them he agrees
in his personal position he probably did
not get to be an anchor in such a
high-profile person and without you know
having to and he brings up you know
being eloquent speaking a certain way
being educated he brings up other things
certainly besides just the way you dress
and he does make a point he makes the
point as you were saying not just for
the black community but for any
teenagers that you know are just not
just a purpley they're probably not
gonna get the job over somebody else who
comes in looking a little bit more work
appropriate right I think him as a high
profile black man was saying speaking to
his community specifically saying that
he agrees and he wouldn't be where he is
and probably his peers wouldn't be where
they were unless they took some sort of
responsibility for their behavior and
the way they present them right so that
that's the part that I find sort of
bizarre about this whole thing is that
the way though it seems white people's
reaction to Don Lemon Don Lemon no
community should have the same opinion
about every anything you know you to me
there shouldn't be one uniform opinion
on anything so the way though even Don's
guest in the original clip on this
immediately attacked him and said oh
you're buddies with O'Reilly now and he
would love what you're saying but
shouldn't the black community like any
community be able to express have a
variety of opinions absolutely of course
it's but can't we do two things at once
well it's it's a much deeper problem and
I think you know it's it's so it's
really hard to agree with Bill O'Reilly
you feel terrible and it's like you know
basically on the surface what he's
saying it's not wrong but it's such a
deep social problem yeah like just being
like oh you know we're different things
and don't gravitate toward gangs and
drugs is so let them eat cake it's not
even fun right you're not necessarily
readily at you know it's not really
accessible the role models that are
telling them to do that having parents
in the home whether you have a father
and a mother whether you have or two
mommies and two daddies but just having
more people there no I mean I mean in
any way having more people to turn to
having mentors in your community getting
you know adequate education that's
funded adequately by the state having
access to clothing because your parents
are actually there and care about what
you wear not just going in you know
whatever okay so it's just yeah we there
needs to be a much deeper discussion but
you're not gonna have that discussion on
Fox News or on Sea
ah because there isn't the time and like
they I mean they should they have they
have 24 hours a day they're just afraid
you'll turn the channel to something
else and so right I mean it's you know
it they need there needs to be a much
deeper discussion right so what and even
us here we're doing this here in six or
eight minutes real quick but it's part
of the problem that we don't seem to be
able to discuss two things at once in
America so everything is one side
screaming one thing the other side
scream the other instead of there in a
way I think they're both making
legitimate points there are there are
obviously racial problems in this
country without question and that
nobody's arguing that but then can dawn
also make his point in any sort of
dialogue and I think what you're
basically saying is not on TV yeah
absolutely right because it does go back
to everything else that you have to go
down to and it's also individuals every
individual is a different situation and
also goes down to teenagers I don't
think when I was a teenager that I was
in any way dressing speaking or acting
inappropriately just to enter the
corporate world like they would have
been like we're not hiring you have pink
hair and you're you know just all the
different pink hair last year and I mean
you know supposedly grown woman so I
think there's lots of different factors
that go into it that if we can't discuss
it right here and we're not on that
cable news pressure to have the ratings
immediately whatever then how could they
ever possibly get to the root of the
problem right and honestly I would like
to know more about Don lemons experience
I would like you know how he got where
he got but again that is something that
is such a long story that TV is just not
gonna give him the time for it I don't
know if he has like a blog or if he's
going to write a book or whatever but I
would like to read that blog or book
yeah all right well I hope in our six or
eight minutes that we just did there we
gave you a little something to think
about something we thought we definitely
solved it all the racial problems and
the cable news problems fall in one
segment pretty pretty amazing
you